mais dans l'ensemble la nuit dernière a
été une nuit de fête à marseille lille
ou encore montpellier juniac pour la
victoire et c'est toute la france qui
chavire
a bordeaux ils sont plus de 40000 a
connu déjà vu le premier votant tantôt
l'ado j'attendais sans ont maintenant
des champions du monde
enfin c'est gagné la même furie sur la
grande place de lille près de vingt
mille personnes
et c'est en couleurs que chacun exprime
sa fierté de la victoire
a lyon le cortège est menée tambour
battant sans égard pour les oreilles
sensibles
ici on claironne facilement sa joie et
on s'amuse de toutes les façons
possibles
il n'y a pas d'âge pour exprimer sa
passion
deux buts de zizou et voilà marseille sa
ville natale qui explose de fierté
installé sur la plage du prado
soixante mille supporteurs un record
d'affluence depuis le début du mondial
nefiach de toi frey schéma nous pousse
avec l'adjonction d'une journée ciel de
toit
à chacun ses héros ici en nouvelle
calédonie comme dans la plupart des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
la fête est encore la fête et avec
toujours toujours le même refrain